european fisheries ministers have
reached an agreement on fishing
opportunities for next year for certain
stocks in eu and some non-eu waters
increasing the number of sustainably
managed stocks this annual process is
based on recommendations from the
european commission taking into account
scientific advice it concerns stocks in
the atlantic the north sea international
fishing where eu vessels take part and
in the black sea the best news is that
we have also succeeded in increasing the
number of stocks that are now managed at
sustainable levels and i can therefore
say that sustainably many stocks are now
abroadly accepted concept across
the european union
fishing opportunity limits are aimed at
keeping stock sustainable they take the
form of total allowable catches or tax
for each stock and each fishing zone
tax are then divided into quotas between
member states
the commission has also briefed
ministers on the way the fish landing
obligations being implemented the rules
are part of recent reform to the common
fishing policy and they'll enter force
in january to ensure that less fish are
thrown away
on farm issues the italian presidency
reported on progress made on legislative
proposals for organic farming the school
fruit vegetable and milk scheme official
controls and plant health agriculture
ministers also looked at challenges to
the dairy sector given price volatility
and the impact of the russian ban in
europe on dairy produce many member
states also supported presidency plans
to strengthen eu policies for young
farmers